je vous dis j'ai un très gros tournoi
voilà donc demain je peux pas je
m'absente puisque je pars dès le matin
voilà donc je te remplace c'est Benjamin
il a mis là donc je ne serai pas là
demain voilà exceptionnellement
exceptionnellement je suis désolé mais
c'est comme ça on s'est arrangé avec la
chaîne donc c'est Benjamin qui viendra
donc les missions coûtera un poil moins
cher
ça se refaire et elle sera là quand même
Mathieu dormeau sera en revanche là bien
sûr dans TPMP people samedi j'ai
Véronique Jannot elle arrive à quelle
heure
ton émission exactement c'est vraiment
un bâtard tu aurais jamais vu une en
fait non mais dis-moi c'est à quelle
heure exactement
le samedi 19h10 à 21h12 ne manquez pas
dans cette émission le retour des poetic
lovers également
allez on va parler d'une image qui a
fait le tour des réseaux qui fait
énormément parler depuis une
intervention télévisée d'Emmanuel Macron
oui
cette année il faut que tu dis ça j'ai
plus robe de toi mec
la menace il y a personne qui menace
inverse personne c'est l'ancien gendarme
toi
j'ai fait l'armée de l'air à Nancy
quel régime c'est quoi depuis que je
suis animateur tout tout le monde le
déteste ici
allez allez
vas-y allez la la starlette de
Pontault-Combault là allez vas-y là
allez dégage c'est bon là
allez allez
c'est bon je sors je reviens pas
inch'Allah
allez allez vas-y allez vas-y allez
vas-y là on va te reconnaître
[Rires]
de Jean-Pierre Mader
salut salut
frérot allez c'est une image qui a fait
le tour des risques
[Rires]
[Musique]
on a besoin de lui
[Rires]
c'est une image qui a fait le tour des
réseaux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]